[Music]
make the foundation of the society a man
who never would err what really needs to
be a two-part story as a single episode
[Applause]
[Music]
overdue Doctor Who review and we are now
up to the doctor's daughter and this
review is brought to you by radio versus
the Martians it's a podcast which means
cost you nothing to check out and give a
listen to hosted by Mike Gillis and
Casey Doran as they discuss all manner
of geeky material they like to call
themselves the McLaughlin group of fur
nerds and yeah that's pretty accurate
cuz they will talk about whatever is on
their mind it might be Star Trek it
might be Batman it might be Game of
Thrones it might be Star Wars maybe
they'll have a guest and sometimes they
take a look at our knowledge for say in
your movie the good and the bad but
they're always entertaining sometimes
even a little insightful check them out
radio versus the Martians calm or
anywhere you get your podcasts so the
doctor's daughter man I have never liked
this episode and the reason I don't like
it is exactly what I said in the intro
this if this was going to work and
here's here's what breaks my heart this
could have worked most of it could have
worked if it was a two-parter but doing
this is one episode none of the stuff
that could have worked if it had
breathing room
does like none of it - almost nothing
here works it's not a disaster it's not
an embarrassment it's not loving
monsters it's not fear her but it's not
good so okay where do we begin
all right well let's start with the
titular doctor's daughter let's start
with Jenny
so Jenny as a character it well first of
all like personal weird nitpicky thing
has nothing to do with anything but
don't you love it how a clone just
barely
created and generated to fight has I'll
iron mascara right anyways so the whole
thing with Jenny being derived from the
doctors
there is a lot of potential there for
her to sort of instill that while first
happened to that sense of loss that he
has about the Timelords and to reawaken
that paternal instinct that he's been
trying to kind of keep dormant because
he's felt the pain of loss from that
before and in terms of her inherent
nature as a fighter and him pushing her
away from that there's tons to work with
there and the episode does in fact try
to work with it but because it has to
share space with this war between humans
in the half and Martha having her own
story completely self-contained within
the half stuff the amount of time needed
for all this stuff regarding Jenny to
develop properly and feel organic and
feel natural as opposed to a list of
bullet points of like these would be
good ideas yes they were good ideas but
this is gonna be work comparison it's
like the finale of Game of Thrones they
had a list of good ideas but they didn't
properly do the build-up to get those
ideas to pay off and I'm referring to
Game of Thrones last season in this case
but I feel like it's like the same kind
of thing they've got a list of themes
and elements to explore with Jenny all
of which are good but because of how
much because they're cramming into one
episode and it has to share story space
with all this other stuff rather than
being a deep character dive into just
her and the doctor none of it lands
properly even though it's technically
doing the right thing exploring the
right themes it's not doing it with any
depth it's not taking the time for any
of it to really work and that just that
follows all the way straight through
toward death I didn't not enough time
was spent for me to form a strong enough
bond with her to care when she died and
then came back and I didn't care then
either and I I keep running to be will
have a lot of affection for Jenny I know
they must exist she's got her own Big
Finish series now I haven't checked it
out yet maybe it's good I don't know I'm
not
I'm not saying the characters inherently
bad I'm saying the way in which the
character is utilized doesn't work so
we've also got Martha back for no reason
other than we're gonna have Martha back
and again I like Martha but it at this
point it's like she never left
she just were just coming off a 2-part
like and I said this last time four
stories
that's how long she was gone and now
she's back for her third episode in a
row getting her own devoted story which
doesn't really add anything like
literally all it does is give her
something to do but there's no reason
for her to be there in the first place
and like they do that and there's
another thing that doesn't work because
not enough time was spent just dwelling
with these elements so she kind of I
guess forms this bond with this half
that she helps and then ultimately that
half dies saving her
but that doesn't land properly either
because well first of all the hath are
all interchangeable there's no
personality in these things I really
don't like the design of this especially
for how much they appear to communicate
with the like how rigid that mask is the
eyes barely moved there's no mouth to
speak of obviously it's just bubbles
that's all we have to go off of and it's
not that it's not it it will be a decent
design for a background alien but like
for the main one you're gonna spend a
lot of time with and try and get us
emotionally invested in one of them no
sorry this design does not work but they
have this half die on the surface saving
Martha and that doesn't land first of
all because as I said the half it's hard
to instill a lot of emotion or
personalities of them then they really
weren't able to do it but that bond
between them if I was ever gonna buy it
it just needed more raw time if this
entire story needs a whole second
episode devoted to it to have this stuff
breathed or failing that take Martha out
of the story remove that entire element
and maybe that would have been enough
time left over for the Jenny stuff to
breathe the way it needs to so that it
works and
it lands but as it stands it just does
not and the other thing with the half
dying is like Martha's her whole Navajo
on the surface but then once she's back
with the doctor not a mention of this
thing like she's back in and she's like
all dirty stuff what happened to you
oh you know I took the surface route not
and I lost a friend like just I took the
surface route he died you seem to care
five minutes ago you don't really say
fine whatever the the twist that works
I like that twist that sort of play off
of generations as a measure of time
because generations is relative and if
you're burning through generations of
soldiers that you can just clone off
yeah you're gonna go through a lot of
generations at a very short amount of
time so I like that that works very well
and that's one of the few things that
did not require more time in order to
work because that's just a twist and as
long as you set up the clues and the
little things which they did and it
didn't require a ton that twist lands
and that works but oh and oh god the
whole that's that this is just cliche so
this just bothers me and this is some of
the other stuff that didn't work with
Jenny is that rather than taking the
time to explore the themes deeper
they're doing stuff like she kind of
seduces a guard like that tired thing
and this is not even like oh you dude
miniature your buddy hover you're
relying or sexuality like I don't care
it's just so tired and droopy and then
the friggin laser beam grid thing and
she does the flips through it like oh
come on like I cannot remember the last
time I was expected to take that
seriously like every time I've seen that
for almost the past twenty years it was
always as a joke so to see this episode
do that seriously
come on so there's little things like
that that just that just dampen it all
the more I do honestly think this could
have been a good story though it really
could have giving the doctor this sort
of mayfly connection to his past to the
things that he's lost that he is
initially reluctant to connect with
because person first of all because of
you know not wanting to relive his
damage but also because of her nature as
a soldier and him trying so desperately
not to ever be that again there there's
so much you could do with that they just
don't take the time to do a proper dive
into the themes of the thing oh also the
whole the whole I never would think like
it's fine as far as a doctor moment goes
but it just rubs me the wrong way that
he ends it with make the foundation of
your new society a man who never would
in other words build your society on me
like I know the doctors arrogant but Wow
ah yeah that that didn't I don't love
that either but like that's minor as far
as the sins of this episode go this this
like I've had some nitpicky things to
say about partners in crime or planet
planet of you'd but like this is this is
the first episode that I think just does
not work as far as seers forward goes
this is the first one I consider a
genuinely skippable episode which is a
shame because I mean if it was a better
episode it'd be like oh let's go let's
watch the episode where David Tennant
met his wife you know before they got
before they got married let's see them
together on screen I would like to enjoy
that I can't cuz it's not good doesn't
work needed to episodes but they didn't
do it oh well the doctor's daughter you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down
let's talk about it buttons links like
button
apparently it's important now also you
know maybe subscribe consider supporting
me on patreon it helps fund things like
improved gear that this cameras new this
year um and things like that so other
links socials merch it's all down there
click on it any link you like it'll take
you someplace you also don't have to if
you really don't want to because at the
end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]